the visual effects that you'll see in  this deleted scene are far from complete  their placeholders but they were going  to be incredibly well rendered you know  this was a cube of shipping containers  that had shrunken down small this was  going to be some kind of biotech here  it's an eye but they were they you know  used it to grow and I and and then this  was a giant waste dump  did he drunken down so there were some  really beneficial uses of this  technology but we just felt it was it  wasn't crucial to our story so we cut it  in this shot here look at the tattoo on  the buyers neck is that a ten rings  tattoo Paul no that's that's not that's  that's the 96 Olympics from Marvel's and  man coming to digital in blu-ray